welcome back if you are still searching
for your soulmate or maybe you want to
amp up your online dating profile we
have called in the expert joining us
today is relationship coach parisa batty
and she's here just in time for peak
dating season thank you so much for
being here of course thank you for
having me it is peak season uh dating
season it starts after christmas and it
goes until valentine's day that's when
everybody has the love on their mind and
they want to get into dating so i want
to give you quick tips on two into how
you can have a better more effective
online dating i know online dating has
been really life-saving for a lot of
people during pandemic but it's also
kind of nerve-wracking you know you get
to be seen by a lot of people put
yourself out there in a really
compressed amount of time and it could
get overwhelming right yeah it's a
little intimidating you don't know which
photos to choose or how to make your bio
stand out so where do you start with all
of it so i would say the most important
piece of this puzzle is your online
profile obviously so what matters the
most is look at it as a online real
estate that you get that you're going to
market yourself so what comes into play
is authentic marketing that's what
matters the most be hundred percent
honest make sure what you have on your
profile completely matches what they're
going to see in person and look at it as
a message that you want to put out in
the work out in the world about you if
there were three personality traits that
you wanted people and your profile
visitors to know about you what would
those be make sure you're sure about
those three trades and then make sure
that all the components of your profile
come hand in hand together to convey
that message to your visitors so your
profile picture is the first impression
the most important one make sure it's
just you not a group of friends together
and put some effort into it you know
like making a resume for a job that
you're applying for so put some effort
into it and the most thing that people
connect over is the description section
and what actually people list as their
hobbies and what they do outside of word
work what makes them thrive in life so
make sure you put details in there and
you're honest and then when you're
matching with someone and you're ready
to make that initial conversation i
liked your tip but not you know we don't
need to send those messages of just to
hay you up
maybe
something about your music taste or
something like that right is what you
recommend doing yeah you're what what
makes you more interesting what makes
you you to be yourself that's the most
important thing being authentic is the
most important thing and you know
there's a little bit of disappointment
that comes with online dating always
because you don't have that personal
touch so you connect with a lot of
people you think they're interested but
they're not or they are interested at
the beginning but they call them like
they ghost you so when anything like
that happens it happens all the time
just know that there is like a million
other people out there and this is not
the end of the world so just brush it
off and keep an open heart and just have
fun with it and you'll find your
soulmate out there thank you so much for
sharing all of these tips and real quick
just if people want to reach out to you
or get tips directly from you where
should they go uh the best way is
instagram parisa.baddie or you can go on
my website perrysobaddy.com thank you so
much you're like giving us all a recipe
for love i love it thank you thank you
mercedes i'll send it over to you thanks
jillian